welcome to GameSpot gameplay well we put
up gameplay at 2:00 and 7:00 p.m.
Pacific every day so you can make your
own decisions about games this is a clip
of a legendary hero named Hawk in
fortnight who he unlocked at random he
has a strong battle cry support ability
to buff allies around it we've seen some
crazy abilities already in Port night
like a lethal robot panda similar to the
one in Dead Rising I have to say it's
really enjoyable to mix shooting and
building in the middle of a frantic
fight plus there's a lot of guns
unlocked
we're just shy of the higher level zones
where we can show you some bigger
enemies and larger forts so stay tuned
this weekend give us the old thumbs up
if you want to see more and subscribe to
get notified let's get to it
[Music]
the forestalling
go to challenge the good job team
it's not bad I think we'll need a little
more blue glow as Lu blow and get ready
to defend the ban let the switch when
you're ready
check your math for update its dormant
le activate final launch sequence when
you're ready
defend the ban we've got a bonus in
place
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
launch at three - good job team that's
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
quick someone airbrush that on velvet
Godspeed Lars be the king of Olympus
guide your journey he always does
[Music]